alors qu'elle suit aujourd'hui quelles
suites judiciaires pour donald trump
quel recours possibles l'analyse de jean
claude beaujour il est avocat et vice
président de l'association france
amérique contestations doivent être
d'abord traitée au niveau de chaque état
dans lequel il y a
contestations du scrutin et si et
éventuellement le l'état ne lui donnait
pas les tribunaux de l'état en question
de lui donner pas gain de cause ils
pourraient saisir dans certaines
conditions la cour suprême le tout doit
être enfermé dans un délai qui le 8
décembre puisque à la date du 8 décembre
toutes les contestations de toute nature
y compris judiciaires doivent être
purgées puisque dès le 14 décembre
le collège des grands électeurs se
réunira pour pouvoir désigner le
candidat qui sera validé par le congrès
au début du mois de janvier c'est le
juge qui est apprécié et qui regardera
est-ce que éventuellement les éléments
factuels dont on parle une fois qu'ils
ont été prouvés une fois qu'ils ont ils
sont pertinents est ce qu'ils sont de
nature à modifier le scooter à altérer
la sincérité du scrutin